All right, folks, welcome back.
This is Episode 9 for the 2022 ICT Mentorship on YouTube.
This lecture is going to be on Power 3, which is Accumulation, Manipulation, and Distribution,
and New York PM Session Opportunities.
All right, so we're looking at the NASDAQ e-mini futures.
This is the continuous chart on TradingView.
So if you look at the daily range of where we've been, we're inside this range here.
Okay, so we have this swing high and this swing low.
Now why am I picking these two reference points?
Well, namely, this is the low most recently after taking out this short-term low.
So we've dug into all the sell-side liquidity resting below that low.
We retraced back up inside of this high to that low.
So we went back up into a premium.
The range high to low, running a fib just to get the 50% level, that gives us equilibrium.
Anything below that is a discount.
Notice how the market traded down on Monday into a deep discount, but did not take out
these lows over here.
But look how we closed on Monday.
We had an indecisive candle.
The body was basically absent.
The opening close was essentially the same thing.
If we have that and the market's trading down into a discount, even though we might
have a low down here that we're targeting, this may require a retracement.
Now notice at the close of Monday's trading, we had an imbalance from this low and this
high.
On Tuesday's trading overnight, the equities markets had a run up into this imbalance here.
So this fair value gap was re-traded to in here.
This low and this high, we'll look at that in reference to the lower timeframes.
This lower level is the low end of the fair value gap on a daily chart, and this level
up here is the upper end of the fair value gap.
I'm taking your attention to Monday's trading, and I want to talk a little bit about Power
3, which is accumulation, distribution, and manipulation.
Generally my teachings are like this.
If I'm bullish, I'm expecting the opening price to be near the low of the day or the
session.
Then it trades lower, making some important low, and then rallies, creates a high, and
then closes near the high of the day.
Now it's not important for you to try to predict the closing price.
What I'm trying to train you to anticipate is the likelihood of the market making some
kind of a fake move, like a Judas swing.
Judas swing is the false move.
Typically in London and in New York session, there are fake runs that start off a move,
and I walked you through it last week on my community tab where I outlined the actual
Judas swing for that particular day.
Using the fair value gap, I outlined the low.
I was only off by a quarter of a point for the low in that range, and it created the
low of the day.
The idea is what I'm going to show you here as well.
On Monday, we had price drop down overnight, consolidated, and then we have a little bit
of a rally ahead of the equities open.
In here, we have 8.30 in the morning.
If you look at 8.30, what do we have?
We have the highs over here.
They're suspect because they're relatively equal highs there, but look what we left here
ahead of 8.30.
We had this huge imbalance.
If we run these highs out after the open at 9.30, it's likely to trade down into that
and rebalance, but watch what it does.
We trade up into that level here, which creates the fair value gap's low end parameter.
Remember, this is Monday's trading.
It sells off.
This line isn't here on Monday.
That's not what we're looking at.
We're looking at the likelihood of coming back down into this area here after taking
these highs out.
If it does so, if it trades back into this imbalance, that's a good candidate to go long.
The imbalance in here, if you go to the left of it, you can see the down close candles.
That's your bullish order block.
The market trades down, hits the order block, and it's an afternoon trade, so it starts
to rally, and then consolidates into close.
Overnight, we create a wicked run last night.
It ran last night, and most of all the move for today was done before we even got to the
opening of the morning.
Had a little bit of a retracement after 8.30, and at 9.30, we consolidated.
I'll talk a little bit about that as a market profile in a moment, but then we dropped down
create an important low today, and then we rally.
It got real close to the fair value gap's high end parameter, but didn't get to it.
It's just like I was mentioning here.
You don't need to try to predict the closing price with power three, which is accumulation,
manipulation.
In other words, if you're bullish, it opens.
Where you think it's going to trade higher, it's going to be most likely a small little
move lower.
That's the move you want to try to go in and hunt along.
If you miss it, you want to try to get along real close to where the opening price is.
Now, the question is going to be, where is the opening price?
Well, I like 8.30, use the opening price here at 8.30, draw that out in time.
Did we go below it?
Yes.
Did we go inside the imbalance?
Did we take out a short-term low?
Yes.
Did we hit an order block?
Was it an optimal trade entry?
Yes.
Lots of factors there.
Over here, same thing.
Did we hit an order block?
Yes.
Here.
Did we trade lower than that?
Yes.
Did it go even lower than that later on?
In the afternoon?
Yes.
Then it rallied, taking out the relative equal highs here, and again, gravitating towards
that upper end of that fair value gap on the daily chart.
Now, I'm in a five-minute chart on that same February 14th, and I want to take you closer
to what price is done here.
Hit imbalance, the lowest portion of it here, with all the down-closed candles here.
Now, this is anchored to the daily bullish order block, but you can see how we traded
into it here with one, two, three, four down-closed candles.
That is a complete order block on this time frame, so consecutive down-closed candles
right before a price surge that has an imbalance.
That's how you find your order blocks.
Okay, so a high-probability order block would be your narrative or your bias is bullish.
You're looking for displacement.
That's this right here.
I'm going to mark it runs real quick, higher, and the down-closed candles, you want to mark
that out and anticipate a return back into that.
Now, again, this level is not there yet.
We don't know this level until Monday's close, so don't be tricked thinking that I have this
level here and I knew it was going to go right through that level and turn, I'm not suggesting
that at all.
What I'm suggesting is watch what happens when it creates that high.
It breaks down.
All this price action here gets overran into a retracement back down into this imbalance
here.
The low of this candle and the high of this candle, that right there, that's your fair
value gap with an order block and optimal trade industry.
Rallies, even though it's sloppy, it's still continuously driving higher.
This high at the close on this day here at, say, 4.30, 4.30 in the afternoon to me, that's
like the close for me.
It trades a little bit later than that and then closes for a little while, and it also
technically closes when the bell rings at 4 o'clock p.m. local time in New York.
Because there's a little bit of trading past that, I like to just look at 4.30 and just
consider that where we are in terms of what we've done for the full range and then determine
what I have left for maybe imbalance or liquidity pools.
Here is that drop down here on a one-minute chart.
It's digging into that order block right here.
If you look real close, let me go back up one slide, I want you to see what I'm showing
you here.
Right here, this price action, see, 14.140, 14.120, this little area right here I'm looking
at on a one-minute chart, 14.140, 14.120 in that vicinity, see that small little gap right
there, see that?
See the swing high?
We trade above it, create a fair value gap there, trade down into it.
This is an afternoon trade.
This is 2 o'clock in the afternoon, local time in New York, inside the order block,
inside the fair value gap, inside a retracement of the fair value gap that sets the stage
of a market run up into a higher retracement.
We don't know if this is going to be the closing parameter for a daily fair value gap.
We don't need to know that yet, but this is a likely scenario to go long, and we can look
for a run back up into this range here, or run the buy stops above here, or maybe in
this side here.
Sloppy run, but nonetheless it's still pressing higher.
Now here's today on the 15th of February, 2022.
Notice what we had, we had this enormous price run overnight in technically the London Session.
Now a lot of you are going to ask, would I have caught this?
No.
No, I wouldn't have caught it.
I would have missed it, and if I was awake I wouldn't have seen it coming, let's just
put it that way.
So this right here was a complete surprise to me when I woke up, saw it, but I want you
to think about when you have these overnight runs that were basically these big moves overnight
before the session begins in New York, when you're trading equities.
This also works with Forex too, so it's important to try not to chase price.
This is what I mean by don't chase it, don't chase it.
Last week when I was commenting and outlining the NASDAQ and giving you a fair value gap
real time explaining to where I thought I was going to draw down to and it created the
New York Session low of the day.
That's what I was outlining, just take a look at it, go back and look at it, you'll see
it's pretty obvious.
The same logic on amplifying that here.
Overnight what was the market doing?
It was rallying.
So when we open up at 8.30, do we go in here and start buying it just because it's gone
up overnight?
No, we don't chase it.
We have to wait.
We have to wait for more information.
What information are we waiting for?
Well typically whenever you see a big run up or a big run down, there's a consolidation
that takes place shortly after.
Now not always, sometimes it just keeps on ripping higher or lower and you'll either
miss a move or if you get lucky maybe you can participate in it.
This is what I typically look for.
So if there's a lot of range movement overnight, what's overnight?
Two o'clock in the morning to five o'clock in the morning.
If we get a big run like that, which is what we're seeing here, right away in my mind I'm
thinking don't trade a lot.
Don't expect a lot of in and out, in and out, perfect precision.
Wait for a real significant price move, otherwise you're going to get chopped up.
Now what does that mean?
Well when we have it opening here at 8.30, look to the left, what do we have?
We have this high here and we have the low over here.
We can use this one because they're relative equal, but I like this one.
Why?
Why do I like this one?
What's below it?
Fair value guy, see that?
So it's likely to trade down after it creates this sloppy opening.
Look at all this movement in here.
Now as a personal study there's two or three YouTubers that I watch that trade the equity
market indices and I'm not trying to say anything bad about them.
I just like to listen to what they're thinking because they don't look at the market like
I do.
I'm not suggesting that they're not profitable because they show live trades.
They get into trades, they take them and sometimes they win and sometimes they don't.
But I like to read kind of like a squawk box what their interpretation of price is and
they're looking at this area in here and it's back and forth.
They think if it goes here it's going to go there, if it goes here it's going to go there.
All these scenarios are going through randomly in their live streams.
So when I'm watching price I'm listening for them to want to be a buyer.
So when they're trying to be a buyer that means they're already hunting a continuation
of this move here.
I want to see a low form.
Now this is what we have for today.
We start going lower first so that's good.
We create a pseudo Judas swing.
But did it create a nice low and turn away from it?
Look at all this back and forth.
And it created these suspect lows in here, relative equal lows.
There's going to be sell side building up below that sell stops.
When it starts to go higher anyone that was long overnight they're going to jam their
stop loss right underneath that.
When this occurs that's the very scenario I'm looking for.
Now right away in my mind here's what I want you to understand.
If there's a big move overnight for equities, this is not Forex, this part is not Forex
it's just for trading like Nasdaq, Dow and E-Mini S&P.
If there's a big run overnight avoid the New York session, don't even mess with the New
York session.
Wait until the other side of lunch at 1 o'clock in the afternoon New York time and then anticipate
the New York lunch lows taken out or the New York morning session lows which is what we
have here.
Notice how we rallied up.
We didn't take out the relative equal highs here that was formed ahead of 7 o'clock in
the morning.
Now this over here we know this range up here is the high end of that fair value gap.
Why do we know that?
Because the 14th stopped trading and it had the indecisive candle on the daily chart.
So it's likely that we might trade up into this range high and this is that range low.
So if we can draw down below that low it was formed initially in the New York session.
We have a fair value gap over here with sell side while we have yet to take out the buy
side liquidity here at around I don't know 14.575 and then get up to that fair value
gap high or the boundary of it, kind of like the resistance level of it.
So this is the draw on liquidity and we have a minor draw on liquidity here with buy side
liquidity.
Look what we have in terms of price action.
The NASDAQ drops down, taking out the sell side, digging into that fair value gap.
See that?
Look at the bodies of the candles.
Isn't that neat how it just respects that level back here?
Now that's not random.
Okay, these are algorithmic principles that are in play and these markets are unbelievably
precise when they are in better conditions.
Right now if you've been trading with live funds or if you've been trying to follow
price action, there's been a lot of it makes a run then it goes into this choppy sideways
and it's very frustrating if you're trying to get like sustained price moves or if you
don't know how to operate in these like these sloppy little ranges like this.
I personally don't think that this is high probability trading.
You can get chopped up.
You can get losing trades.
You can draw your account down.
If you don't control yourself, you can blow your account in these types of conditions.
How do you avoid that?
How do you avoid running out your account and then scaling back if you're a high frequency
type of a trader, how do you draw back on the frequency and look for the better setups?
What I'm showing you here, you wait.
You don't chase the overnight run and you wait for them to give you a low that everybody
overnight will want to put their stop loss right beneath that after it starts a rally
above it.
It's even better when you don't have this high taken out yet.
See how I took it up here and it just went right down for him.
That's engineering liquidity.
It runs up, consolidates, creates a low, starts to rally and everybody's thinking, I don't
want to lose my profits.
I don't want to lose out on making more money, but I have to put a stop loss right here because
the books tell me I have to do that.
So I did the same kind of stuff, folks.
I'm not trying to talk down anybody, but I'm just repeating what a retail trader's mindset
would be and the logic behind this.
So the narrative with this day was the stops were trailed below these lows, the afternoon
session again creates the low of the day, takes the sell-side liquidity out into a fair
value gap and then rallies.
Now in here, I'm going to teach you a little bit more about that much.
Notice we don't really have a fair value gap down here, but it gives us the basis for expecting
the price to start to rally into the afternoon.
Now at two o'clock in the afternoon, 1400 on this trading view chart, that starts two
o'clock in the afternoon in New York local time.
We have the market trading down into an imbalance over here, liquidity resting below these relative
equal lows is taken out.
So what are we looking at?
We've seen a price run that we don't think needs to come back down there because the
logic is the overnight stops have been ran out down here and there's no reason for the
market to want to come back down there.
But we have this low and these relative equal lows here post New York lunch.
New York lunch is noon to one o'clock in the afternoon in New York local time.
So the imbalance we trade down into that, what's the likelihood of it coming all the
way through the imbalance and then going after that low?
Not likely, not likely, not after seeing this run here.
They don't want to give these traders another chance to get back in, they got stopped out.
So it's going to be a little bit more sneakier when they make these new setups to continue
on to a higher run.
So they take out the sell side below these relative equal lows, take those stops out
and then it rallies and drops back down.
Now here, watch, we have a swing high right here.
It breaks it.
Does it trade above that?
Yes.
Was it energetic?
Does it have a fair value gap?
Yes.
So now the market trades down into it here, creates a short term low.
You could be a buyer there.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But say you missed it.
Say you just, I mean this is a one minute chart.
Say you missed it and the market starts to run off like this, but then it gives you another
opportunity.
I've had many times trades form just like this where I was looking for something.
I was waiting for a setup to happen.
Either my cell phone's buzzing or I grab a drink, it's just outside of reach.
I got to go walk over to the other end of the desk and grab it and then all of a sudden
here you go.
I miss it.
It takes off.
The fair value gap is even better when you have the cell side equity resting below a
short term low and the drop down into it here, you can use that low as your entry or minus
one tick.
This short term low forms at 234 PM.
Now if you look at the low figure up here, that value represents that candle right there.
So that's why you see it highlighted here.
When I took a screenshot, I'm holding underneath this candle so that way the reference points
up here are directly related to this candle.
So you can see the low is 14,528 and a half.
So you could be a buyer on a limit at 14,528 and a quarter or maybe if you want to try
to reach for the 28 even number.
Either way, that's a nice place to put a limit order in.
The short term low down here after the fair value gap forms, that's where your stop loss
is.
That's the rules.
So you have an entry point, your stop and between the two of them, it works out to be,
let's say you have 14 and a quarter in terms of risk.
So 14 and a quarter points or handles of total risk.
And let's assume that you were trading on six contracts on the micro.
You're essentially looking at buying and risking $85 to make about $300.
So it's about 3.5 to 1 reward to risk.
Thereabouts I'm roughing out.
I don't have a calculator in front of me.
Folks, just do the math.
Now here this value is important because I want you to see in these conditions you can't
expect it to be perfect.
You can't be expecting to be in there at the lowest point, no draw down, no heat on the
position and then it just goes in your favor.
Don't think like that.
You can see on this candle, if you would have bought here, you would have had nine points
of heat or basically $54 if you were trading six micros.
Now obviously it goes up more than that if you're trading one mini because it's $20 per
handle.
But overall this is a nice little setup with the afternoon using the logic over here.
Even if it doesn't give us a fair value gap, the setups that I'm teaching you to use, using
the fair value gap, afternoon taking the stops.
It provides the baseline for bias for the afternoon.
Now what did I teach you here?
I taught you that you can use these reference points with the underlying sentiment that's
already in motion.
If you didn't trade overnight and take that big run, I didn't get any of that run.
I didn't do anything with that.
If you missed that, it doesn't matter because that is something that's going to give you
more insight and it tells you when to avoid the morning session.
Don't trade it.
Everybody's going to be doing what?
Think about it.
Everybody woke up and saw these markets and they all wanted to do what?
They wanted to buy it because it's going up a lot and they want to chase it.
That idea leads many times to losing trades and then it starts this cycle where you go
into this chasing, chasing, chasing and then when the market does these sideways consolidations
and sloppy choppy market conditions, it's literally like a blowtorch on your account.
If you don't know how to stop or if you don't know what you're doing, you can literally
talk yourself into millions of trades and then draw the account down.
Last slide and just to hammer this down.
This is zoomed in on a one minute chart.
Swing high, broken, fair value cap right there and we have that short term low here, unloaded
in here.
That's where you would be basically entering on with that idea of trading below that is
where the sell stops are, trading below that.
Now it goes below that.
Now some of you have mentioned in the comment section, does this invalidate the fair value
gap?
No, it does not.
The idea is the fair value gaps, well look at the, look at the body of this candle here.
Isn't that respecting that?
Yes.
So in my mind I'm thinking, well I know prices sometimes, especially the way it is right
now, it's very volatile.
So I'm permitting a greater level of imperfection in price delivery and then using the logic
of the fair value gap as the basis for my entry idea and then using the stop premise
which it didn't get here, it didn't stop you out.
You had basically what, five, what was that, five or so more handles before you would have
been stopped.
Now watching it live might make you a little nervous but at some point folks you're going
to have to get used to, if you're going to trade like this in these really little time
frames and you're trying to be very nimble, you're going to have to learn to trust the
setups and let the stops do their jobs and if they, if it gets stopped out, that's just
one trade you got wrong.
It's not your career.
Look for the next one.
Now I'm going to throw this in here as a bonus but take it for what it is.
It rallies here, takes off and does not take out that, the buy side liquidity resting above
here did not get taken here yet and then we had this imbalance and it trades down into
it and then hits what, the order block.
That's a buy and you can, if you miss this one, you can pick up this one based on the
logic I teach on the YouTube channel.
So this is actually something that's taught in the YouTube channel.
This whole pattern here is exactly right out of my high probability short term trading
or scalping series.
I can't remember exactly what the title was but this pattern is right in that and then
it runs for that liquidity there.
So there's two setups there.
So I took something from the free lessons that's already on the YouTube channel and
also amplifying something I've been teaching in this mentorship series.
Hopefully you found this one insightful and until I talk to you next time, be safe.